هل طلبت بزياده راتبك لتعويض غلاء الاسعار
اذا لم تكن قد فعلت حتى الان فعليك
مشاهدته هذا الفيديو اولا يجب ان تواجهها
الحجج التي سيواجهك بها مديرك سيخبرك اني
مئات الملايين في الدول المتقدمه يعانون
من ارتفاع الاسعار وان التضخم وصل الى
مستويات الى مثيل لها منذ 40 عاما ولو ان
هضرت اقل بكثير في السعوديه وبعض دول
الخليج وقد يخبرك ايضا ان الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه صعبه في العالم كله وان بعض
اكبر الشركات التكنولوجيا العالميه تسرح
عددا كبيرا من موظفها مثل امازون وغيرها
الكثير كل هذا صحيح لكن هناك جانب اخر
للقصه في الولايات المتحده تحديدا سجل
ساعه العمل زياده بنسبه 4.6% في ديسمبر
على اساس ثانوي
اكثر من ذلك اظهر مسح البنك الاحتياطي
الفدرالي في اتلانتا ان الشركات اعطت
زيادات لموظفيها باعلى وتيره منذ 25 عاما
خوفا من انتقالهم الى شركات اخرى وبنسبه
خمسه ونصف في المئه على اساس سنوي حتى
نهايه نوفمبر بين الموظفون الذين انتقلوا
من شركه الى اخرى على زيادات بمعدل 7.7 في
المئه في الفتره نفسها
بالطبع معظم الموظفين لم يشعر بتحسن
اوضاعهم الماديه والسبب ان التضخم يبقى
اعلى من معادله زيادات الرواتب بنقطتين
قويتين تقريبا هذا في امريكا
اما في الاقتصادات الناشئه التي يصل تضخم
السنوي فيها الى 70 في المئه او اكثر مثل
تركيا فلا شك ان الاوضاع اصعب بكثير
اخبرنا كيف هو الحال في بلدك وكيف يسيل
السباق بين التضخم وزياده الرواتب